david is this a good case uh if what mr.
bhaskar ish and the neighbor alleges is
true I think it's a pretty strong case
you know what he's alleging is that this
house was worth 4.3 million dollars or
more and that mr. Zuckerberg wanted to
buy the house and what he ended up
promising was 1.7 million dollars as a
cash payment or some sort of payment
along with promises to introduce him to
his valuable social network and that
that would be worth significant amounts
of money and if that promise was made
and if that promise was exchanged for as
part of this deal for purchasing mr.
braska Russians house I think it
definitely is a pretty strong case um to
talk about the law behind this I mean
there's no written agreement from what I
can understand there's no formal
contract or have any kind right and
that's a great question now we usually
think of contracts as written documents
right and in fact there was a written
document here there was a document
basically stating are you still there
I'm still here okay I'm sorry uh I'm
laptop went off for a second normally we
think of written contracts and here we
had a written contract for the sale of
the estate and nowhere in that written
document was there any mention of these
promises from mr. Zuckerberg so you
might think that that was enough to turn
the tide in favor of mr. Zuckerberg but
in fact anybody who's taking even a few
days of contracts law knows that oral
promises can be just as good as written
promises and it's really just a matter
of proving that they exist California
actually takes a very liberal approach
as you might suspect with allowing oral
promises to come into the written
document and so even though that's not
within what they might call the four
corners of the written document uh if he
can provide evidence that mr. Zuckerberg
made this promise and that that promise
was made in exchange for purchasing the
home then I think he will prevail and so
far he's come up with some some pretty
good evidence that suggests that that at
least Zuckerberg made that promise yeah
it's also interesting that uh Bhaskar
sarian if I'm pronouncing his name
correctly he's sooo this isn't his first
lawsuit does that matter
here is if he's a particular litigious
person from a procedural or purely legal
matter no but of course you know juries
take lots of things into account and so
at the end of the day the jury's might
well look at the vicious tackett's are
the hard knocks tactics that are being
used by bhaskar ition as well as his
previous litigious pneus and maybe they
might hold that against him on the other
hand you might have juries looking at
mr. Zuckerberg and holding unfavorable
opinion so at the end of the day you put
12 people on a panel give them lots of
time to discuss the matters and who
knows what what verdict they come out
with how could damage as possible of
potential business deals possibly be
measured that's a great question and and
that should and probably is one it is it
is going to be one of Zachary Berg's
arguments that this particular promise
is so indefinite that course can't
possibly enforce it I think Voss
Christians attorneys have however found
a way around that I think it is
difficult to damage measure these types
of damages but what they're asking for
is not the value of the promises what
they're asking for is to rescind or undo
this deal bhaskar ation will give back
the 1.7 million dollars plus interest
and he will receive the house back
unwinding the deals perfectly within the
courts authority and it would get around
that problem of measuring the damages of
the what's the value of these promises
are these introductions and youth but
you sounds like you really think that's
this is case in mark zuckerberg is gonna
lose uh you know based purely on what
we've seen in the median and court
filings you know like i'd say these
falling propositions if everything that
Bhaskar ition has alleged is true he
will probably prevail again we don't
know what might happen with the jury but
the law is probably on his side second
that we've had two pieces of evidence
come out that seemed to point to the
supporting his version of the facts one
today or the New York Times just
reported today that Oscar itions
attorneys filed an affidavit on behalf
of his real estate broker saying that he
didn't have indeed have an offer four
point three million dollars on this
phone
that he sold the home for 1.7 million
dollars a very steep discount from that
market price if that offer actually came
was was in existence and we have some
evidence now that it was then that is
one pretty strong data point that mr.
braska rishon was was exchanging this
for something else of value this promise
potentially I'm the second piece of
evidence that's pretty damning against
mr. Zuckerberg is an email from one of
his advisors in which they state that
Zuckerberg did in fact make a promise to
make some light introductions on behalf
of Oscar ition that email seems to
indicate that that boss Grisham's
version of the facts may be true and so
taken together I think that this tends
to support his allegations